[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
let me bring in marcus hayes he covers
this this is his job philadelphia
inquire columnist and uh
marcus i i saw the headline not that you
wrote the headline ben simmons comes
crawling back to the sixers to save
money if not face
all right where are we in this situation
with ben simmons and the 76ers
actually right had that headline i
didn't know it would stand but it passed
muster i guess
um you know i think we're in a spot
where
the sixers
have a guy they would like to train but
they would like to get value for him and
i think the only way that happens is
that ben simmons actually plays games
like mclovin said and proves that okay
maybe i'm a little bit better player
i will be invested i will be
professional because the worst thing he
could do he did
he said
not only will i not play hard for you
and take risks on the court
i will not be accountable for it
afterward and at the first whiff of
controversy i'm going to take my ball
and go home
that
i think
rich paul and clutch sports and ben
simmons understand now
that he has to rebuild his image and
prove that he's worth something because
the sixers right now probably couldn't
get very much for him at all
because what happens if he does the same
thing next year for another team
and they're in the same situation
how much of this is just hey i'm losing
a lot of money and this hold out is not
working i'd say if there were more than
a hundred percent it would be more than
100
um this is all about i mean you have to
realize who ben simmons is he came to
lsu because the nba required you at that
point to go to lsu there weren't avenues
that exist now
to avoid one year of college
played indifferently
didn't go to class
and told everyone i'm just here so i
don't get fined like march on lynch you
know so
he took that year he wasted that year of
his teammates time his coaches time lsu
scholarship money so he could get to the
point where he could make more money he
knew he was talented he knew he was
going to be the number one overall pick
i said all that to say ben simmons only
cares about money
that's it he wants to make as much money
as quickly as possible he doesn't care
who for he doesn't care if he wins he
doesn't care
you know how he makes it he just wants
to make that money be famous be
photographed at wimbledon and be ben
simmons and it's kind of a i i guess
it's kind of an indication of who we are
in our time
but i
it just doesn't work in that city i mean
there are other cities where it can work
right it doesn't work there i i just
can't imagine what the local reaction is
going to be that that first game and
like he misses a free throw or he won't
take as she uh no three here i mean
that's a tough audience man tough
audience marcus
there's nowhere like it for all four
sports that's the thing like
there's nothing like the intensity and
passion in philadelphia
for all four sports in any any town
except maybe boston boston's rough too
you know he would have a hard time
selling this in boston but i mean you
know that there were times when the
patriots could get away with anything so
um yeah it'll be it'll be ugly but it
also depends on how he comports himself
over the next couple of weeks if he's
recalcitrant if he's humble
if he is accessible
if he
asks for forgiveness nobody forgives
like philadelphia
especially if you're going to be in
their town if you're going to be one of
them
then philadelphia will take you back and
worship you maybe more so than if you'd
succeeded
i mean if ben simmons says you know what
you guys were right i was wrong i'm
gonna take threes i'm gonna help win
i'll play power forward if i have to
and they win he'll be as popular as nick
foles but is he capable of doing
that i don't know i mean
that that he's just been such a weird
kid i remember he was incredibly
impressive at the uh pre-draft uh media
availability
he made sure that he was the last person
to show up at the hotel in new york the
year he was drafted to show up in the
ballroom he came with an entourage
he
he dressed like a businessman
he acted like a businessman he was
it was almost as if he was a movie
character
i believe that that's how he lives his
life
like he's in a movie like it's not real
like there's really no accountability
and that he can do no wrong because he's
writing the script so i don't know if
his script will ever include any sort of
mia culpa stock
what is his value around the league is
that what this comes down to that
their teams
the rest of the league doesn't value him
the way the sixers think they should
value him
well you have to understand the sixers
perspective as it pertains to joel
embiid's window
if you think that joel embiid can win
for the next three to five years before
his body collapses because he gets hurt
all the time
if that's his window you have to
compliment him with players who are
going to help win in that window because
that's going to be it for a long time
there might not be
a player
in the second tier of players
who can help them win the way ben
simmons can win right now even if he
moved him to power forward which is his
natural position anyway you know he's
more draymond green than he is chris
paul so
all that said the sixers believe they
have to get a solid second piece that
could be a first piece because joel
embiid gets hurt all the time to replace
ben simmons and they can't afford to
take taking anything less would be
forfeiting this window so yes they
overvalue ben simmons because of the the
way they frame it is how can we win in
this window with joel embiid
he's marcus hayes the philadelphia
enquirer columnist we're talking about
ben simmons reporting back to the
philadelphia 76ers i've mentioned this a
couple of times and maybe this has to do
with their backgrounds giannis comes
over here he's not pampered he is an
unknown he fights for everything and
he's not a fair afraid of failure marcus
like he'll go to the line and his
free-throw shooting is worse than mine
his three-point shooting is worse than
mine but he never stops he still
keeps playing ben has a fear of failure
being embarrassed where giannis doesn't
and and to me that's a big difference in
giannis is never going to stop he's
always trying he plays hard and ben it
feels like he goes up
you know i've been pampered i don't want
to be embarrassed here i don't want to
be on social media here whereas giannis
doesn't give a damn about that
well you you hit the nail on the head
the background is everything uh ben
reminds me a lot of a kobe bryant
without the heart
he was you know he's an international
sophisticated great-looking
well-presented smart guy
who was raised by a professional
international professional basketball
player in the lap of luxury with a lot
of fame the difference between kobe and
ben is ben thinks that he's arrived kobe
wanted to be mike
giannis wants to be the best player he
can be
i can't tell you the depth of my
admiration
for giannis watching him warm up
watching his pre-game routine watching
him airball threes and free throws it
just it's just and he you know he's
going to take them in the game and he's
going to airball them in the game but
you know for giannis it's the next step
it's the next play it's how can i win
for ben simmons it's all about style
it's all about how do i look it's all
about doing it my way because one guy's
spoiled and one guy isn't
if i ask doc rivers and ask him for an
honest answer do you want ben simmons
back what do you think doc says
absolutely i mean he would love to have
ben simmons in any iteration because it
helps win regular season games and doc's
a brilliant coach i think that he thinks
he can win despite ben simmons
deficiencies
which might mean moving ben simmons off
the point again that you remember the
philadelphia 76ers did that against the
toronto raptors and put jimmy butler at
the point and it worked because ben
simmons is a gifted powerful he's a hall
of fame power forward you know you can
call him an all-star point guard but
he's not you know he's not one of the
top you know 10 point guards in the
league as you define true point guards
so that said i don't know
maybe not the top ten maybe not the not
maybe not the top six or seven
but the point is
doc rivers believes he can win with ben
simmons because ben simmons is really
good he's an elite perimeter defender
he's an excellent rebounder he could be
even better rebounder as joel embiid
mentioned um and he runs the fast break
almost as well as anybody in the nba in
part because it only like giannis it
only takes him three steps to get from
free throw line and free throw up so
yeah doc rivers would love to have ben
simmons back
and imagine if doc rivers is the coach
that wins with ben simmons and breaks
through with ben simmons i mean doc
rivers is probably a hall of fame coach
already this would be you know the
cherry on top for his career
would you rather have ben or kyrie
you know we had that conversation a lot
here in the last week
if ben is on your team and shows up he's
probably more valuable than kyrie
because you don't know if kyrie's not
going to show up and you don't know how
hard he's going to play and you don't
know how hurt he's going to play
so kyrie is the ultimate wild card i
mean i contended when kyrie was in
cleveland he lebron james might have
been the second best player on that team
you know the second most skilled player
offensively anyway on that team kyrie
irving is a special special entity
but he's special in other ways too
kyrie is kanye west
like there's there's brilliance but
there's unpredictability and crazy and
calculated at the same time
well that's the thing i'm not sure they
calculate as much as we i think they
recover sometimes and we allow them to
recover
but
you know
they're they are so narcissistic the
world revolves around them to such a
degree
that they completely lack respect for
perspective the same thing is true of
ben to a degree and carson wentz here in
philadelphia you know
the utter lack of self-awareness and
humility among those four people is
astonishing but again it might be a sign
of the times we live in where social
media can make you a star if you're just
you know clever with 240 characters
great insight really appreciate your
time marcus thanks for joining us and uh
we'll be following we'll be following
those headlines you're writing
thanks for having me dan thanks guys
that's marcus hayes philadelphia and
choir columnist